hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein vegetarisches
hauptgericht und vor wird heute indisch
wir machen einen linsencurry mit spinat
das essen wie immer ganz gerne morath
und ja das noch heute zu ich liebe die
indische küche ich auch weil sich die
gewürze sind gehe niemals etwas vom
geschmack her immer was ganz ganz
anderes ist also auch die türkische
findet sich oft auch in italienischen
eine griechische küche des junis hinzu
mittelmeer oder in dieser stadt komplett
sich kunden an last so richtig tolle
gewürze ich zeige euch noch kurz die
zutaten an zutaten braucht es etwas
olivenöl 2 zwiebeln eine knoblauchzehe
ein stück ingwer chili schoten habe ich
noch koriander einen grund eine
paprikaschote eineinhalb kurkuma einen
hut terrassen seltsamen und einen
teelöffel bockshornklee 450 gramm linsen
die ich bereits heiß abgewaschen
da vorne habe ich noch curry blätter 600
milliliter kokosmilch 700 milliliter
wasser und 300 gramm baby spinat und
jetzt nehme ich zuerst die
knoblauchzehen und die zwiebel und zwar
bis jetzt alles fein gehackt ich mache
das jetzt gleich einem mixer denn es uns
wirklich richtig früher püriert werden
also meine eltern und freunde so ist
bollywood kino angeschaut auf türkisch
synchronisiert man richtig lustig
die chili schoten nämlich auch ich hatte
ja früher eine indische tanzgruppe ich
weiß noch daran erinnern
ja stimmt da fällt mir gerade bullish
sind ich meine ich dachte es ja sagen
was wir konnten in darwin eine geldbörse
finderlohn
was mache ich darf es ein stück
irgendwann habe ich jetzt jedoch und
dann nämlich eigentlich immer so den
hauptteil der schale weg dann die rote
paprika
das muss alles wirklich nur grob
gestückelt werden und den rest mache ich
denn neben der maschine oder mit dem
pürierstab und jetzt nehme ich noch die
koriander blätter und zwar die
titelblätter weg und benutze jetzt die
stiele für die paste und koriander
bekomme ich auch im supermarkt gehen an
fischen also bloß gibt es alles falsch
gemacht was brauchen nicht jetzt gebe
ich dieses ganze gemüse alle zwiebel
knoblauch ingwer chili paprika und
koriander stille mit jedem mixa jetzt
fixieren videos gemacht
diesen trick dann noch eine prise salz
und pfeffer jetzt wird es alles rein
gemixt
jetzt gebe ich einen esslöffel olivenöl
in einem topf erhitzen
ich hab kein fleisch gesehen nicht schon
wieder
jetzt nehme ich hier auch die karibik
die bekommt man in asia läden aber wenn
ihr dies nicht findet ist es auch nicht
schlimm
also das ist kein muss und dann nehme
ich jetzt etwa fünf blätter bzw
ja doch besser ist ein curry blätter
ja ich wusste gar nicht dass ein baum
wächst das kann sich eine gewürzmischung
aber ich glaube es geht nicht nur mir so
es gibt viele die virtuelle leute gar
nicht wissen ist es ein baum ist ein
strauch
das öl ist jetzt kommen da die gewürze
mit reiner zusammen
bockshornklee koma
berührt dann auch direkt
da kommen jetzt noch die curry blätter
mit rein und werden einfach so ein bis
zwei minuten mit angeschwitzt auch meine
augen
jetzt spiele ich mit wasser noch jede
diese schüssel aus weil es nicht richtig
genial ist richtig über wasser mit rein
dann auch direkt die kokosmilch
das rezept morath ist übrigens nicht nur
ein vegetarisches sondern sogar ein
veganes rezept und jetzt auch noch die
linsen aufkochen und dann so etwa 15 bis
20 minuten kochen bis die linsen weich
sind
in der zwischenzeit werde schon mal den
spinat waschen dann noch die tomaten
vorbereiten denn da gibt es einen warmen
tomaten salat dazu und bei uns gibt es
dazu im warmen tomaten salat
für den tomaten salat brauche ich 750
gramm cocktailtomaten 115 flug ein
treffer 15 teelöffel senfkörner eine bio
zitrone und 2 knoblauchzehen nämlich
bereits halbiert und natürlich einen
esslöffel olivenöl das geht es auch ganz
einfach also die linsen sind es auch
fast gar schon jetzt nehme ich zuerst
die knoblauchzehe fuhr ich auch total
und die hab ich jetzt ganz fein
insoferne schreiben jetzt nämlich die
bio zitrone damit darauf achten dass die
bio ist und eben ungespritzt ist und da
nehme ich jetzt die hälfte man kann die
schale mit verzehren da kommen jetzt
erst mal die kerne raus
und der rest wird jetzt fein gehackt
zitronen und stücke gebe ich jetzt mit
zum knoblauch und jetzt muss ich nur
noch die tomaten halbieren
und da gibt's einen einfachen trick
damit jetzt nicht fasst das kilo tomaten
alle einzeln zerkleinern ist in dem
zweiteiler sind so zwei fast flachen
teller dann legt die tomaten dazwischen
einen teller drauf und jetzt mit einem
großen messer an durchfall
dann sind alle tomaten schön halbiert
jetzt gebe ich einen esslöffel olivenöl
in einer pfanne die pfanne sitzt bereits
heiß da kommt jetzt die gewürze und
zitronenschalen und auch das kind und
auch dies ein kleiner sieg noch 10 3
durch schwenken
da kommen jetzt noch die tomaten
betreuung mit müssen sie nur so 23
minuten mit gerührt werden
den restlichen zitronensaft presse ich
jetzt auch noch ein
und würzen mit salz und pfeffer
der tomaten salat ist jetzt fertig mit
nur noch abgeschmeckt werden also
einfach probieren ob noch software
versehen
jetzt kann ich hier das linsencurry noch
fertigstellen batterien sind jetzt
richtig schön weiß jetzt kommt darauf
der spinat mit dazu und bei spinat ist
es immer so dass sie dem hatte nach
ziemlich viel aus aber der fällt gleich
also direkt alles nicht sein spiel
einmal um so ist auch im monatslohn der
sieht ziemlich viel aus oder gleich
wieder weg spielen
ich liebte es auch nicht mag das ein
curry mit spinat total.com augen machen
ballack oder sowas spinat rein und jetzt
hier auch noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
zum curry gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen von einem selbstgemachten
masala gewiss mit rein da findet ihr das
rezept auch schon auf meinem blog und in
einem video
und dann müsste einfach selber
abschmecken wie stark er das gerne haben
möchte ich gebe es nur einen halben
teelöffel mit rein und dann kann ich im
prinzip auch schon alles anrichten
so jetzt kann ich direkt alles servieren
bei uns gibt es da einen indischen
basmati reis mit dazu kommt da alles
komplett vegetarisch lang riecht
irgendwie hätte verbindet es halt immer
mit dem indischen genau und dann auf
dieser warme tomatensalat also der
schmeckt richtig gegengehalten um ein
handyklingeln ich mache es kurz aus
unglaublich sagt flugmodus dann stört
mich das nicht beim dreh aber nie lässt
die hand immer so hier bitteschön im rat
jetzt probiere ich direkt mal von hier
ein bisschen spinat
es heisst deuce heißt bisschen also ich
hab die tomaten eben schon probiert und
ich finde diesen tomatensalat wickens
genial diesmal ohne witze der zitrone
mit der schärfe der branche ist kein
fleisch mehr sterne ehrlich vielleicht
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr spiel
gemacht weil der spinat kommt mir vor
wie lampen auch die kombination vor
allem mit diesem indischen gewürzen gut
die linsen sind wirklich total würzig
total lecker bringt die soße auch so
schön sämige schrieb mit dem kombinat
richtig toll und die tomaten finde ich
schon alles raus finden statt auch jetzt
ohne witz jemand der als genial wirklich
vegetarisch vegan sogar vegan sogar ohne
tierische braun und vegan noch wegen
meckerns also falls ihr dieses rezept
nach machen wollte jeder service - block
der etat stehen noch mal alle zutaten
und ich hoffe dass ich dieses rezept
gefallen hat und jetzt ausprobieren
werdet und ich freue mich natürlich auf
euer feedback also bis zum nächsten mal
gesund schmeckt so lecker wirklich um
rein
ein abschlusslied
mit